[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen Deutschland galt mal
als Apotheke der Welt
mittlerweile muss man sich in diesem
Land Sorgen machen ob die
Grundversorgung mit Medikamenten noch
funktioniert als hätte ohnehin nicht
schon genug Sorgen wer krank ist und
dringend auf bestimmte Mittel angewiesen
verzweifelte Eltern die im Ausland nach
Arzneien für ihre kranken Kinder
fahrenden müssen das ist kein Zustand
mehr das ist ein Skandal man fühlt sich
wie in einem Entwicklungsland sagt ein
Chirurg heute das Problem hat viele
Ursachen es ist auch Ergebnis einer
verfehlten Gesundheitspolitik jetzt
sollen die Festbeträge für bestimmte
kindermedikamente vorübergehend
ausgesetzt werden die Krankenkassen
würden also mehr dafür bezahlen ob der
Mangel damit schnell behoben wird ist
umstritten noch mehr Zweifel gibt es ist
ob er so dauerhaft bekämpft werden kann
Daniel pontzen
eine Berliner Kinderarztpraxis heute
Nachmittag der Andrang nicht mehr ganz
so groß wie noch im Dezember die
arzneiengpässe aber bleiben massiv bei
fiebersäften etwa und besonders kritisch
bei Antibiotika wo statt der erste oder
zweit oft nur die drittbeste Ware
verfügbar ist
das führt dann dazu dass Krankheiten
nicht mehr adäquat behandelt werden
können das führt dazu dass Resistenzen
vermehrt auftreten werden und das ist
etwas was in dieser Form so noch nicht
aufgetreten ist und auch nicht
akzeptabel ist schmerzhaft deutlich wird
dies als im Dezember immer mehr Deutsche
ins benachbarte Ausland fahren wie hier
in die Niederlande um Medikamente zu
besorgen der Grund produziert werden die
zu großen Teilen in Indien und China
Corona und Krieg haben auch hier die
Märkte durcheinander gebracht etwas für
Produktions Engpässe gesorgt geliefert
wurde dann nicht nur weniger sondern vor
allem erst einmal dorthin wo besser
bezahlt wird als in Deutschland wo es
niedrige gedeckelte Festbeträge gibt
vollmundig verkündete der
Gesundheitsminister dann kurz vor
Weihnachten wir müssen diese
arzneimittel für Kinder aus den
Festbeträgen herausnehmen so dass sie
auch teurer verkauft werden aber ich
heute schon reagieren dass die
Krankenkassen angewiesen werden 50% mehr
zu zahlen als sie sind Festbetrag
anweisen aber konnte die Kassen gar
nicht nach einigen Wochen nun haben sie
dennoch reagiert die Festbeträge sogar
vollständig ausgesetzt für fertig
Arzneimittel mit Ibuprofen und
Paracetamol und für Antibiotika ab
Februar für drei Monate das heißt die
Hersteller können dann mit ihren
Medikamenten mehr in Deutschland
verdienen wie von Lauterbach gewünscht
die pharmindustrie hat immer gesagt wenn
wir höhere Preise bekommen dann machen
wir die Regale wieder voll jetzt
bekommen sie höhere Preise jetzt muss
die fahrindustrie liefern oder sie hat
geblöft doch ob ein kurzfristiges
umleiten der Arzneien auf den deutschen
Markt überhaupt möglich ist ebenfalls
fraglich Skepsis bei den deutschen
Herstellern unsere Unternehmen
produzieren derzeit rund um die Uhr es
gibt keine wahre die kurzfristig auf den
Markt kommen könnte nur weil sich der
Preis für drei Monate erhöht wichtig sei
dass die avisierte langfristige Änderung
per Gesetz nun schnell umgesetzt werde
hierzu hatte Lauterbach kurz vor
Weihnachten Eckpunkte vorgelegt darunter
Festbeträge die dauerhaft 50% höher sind
und eine Stärkung europäische Hersteller
für die Kassen ist zudem zweierlei
zentral immer dann wenn sich irgendwo
abzeichnet das in zwei Monaten drei
Monaten in den Apotheken Lieferproblem
ankommt dann muss es eine Meldepflicht
geben damit reagiert werden kann und das
zweite ist zwischen Lager wir brauchen
Zwischenlager damit eben solche
Lieferschwierigkeiten abgepuffert werden
können bis Ende Januar werde Lauterbach
einen konkreten Gesetzentwurf vorlegen
heißt es aus dem Ministerium der akute
Mangel bleibt einstweilen bestehen
unser nächstes Thema wir haben es heute
endgültig schwarz auf weiß vom
europäischen
erdbeobachtungsprogramm Kopernikus die
vergangenen acht Jahre waren weltweit
die wärmsten überhaupt und der letzte
Sommer war der bisher heißeste der
gemessen wurde in Europa
2022 hat gleich reihenweise negativ
Rekorde gebrochen wir sehen es hier 12
europäische Länder waren besonders
betroffen vor allem im Süden und Westen
aber auch die baltischen Staaten und
Österreich überall Monate mit nie zuvor
registrierten Temperaturen
das sind die Daten die die Welt drängen
müssten die Klimakrise zu bekämpfen wie
das gehen soll und wie schnell darüber
gibt es nach wie vor Streit und damit
sind wir bei einem Dorf im rheinischen
Braunkohle Revier in dem der Ton heute
deutlich aggressiver wird die Polizei
hat heute in lützerath damit begonnen
Barrikaden zu entfernen Aktivisten
stemmen sich mit Macht dagegen ab morgen
rechnen Beobachter damit dass die
Handvoll besetzte Häuser geräumt wird
damit der Energiekonzern RWE die
darunter liegende Kohle Abbaggern kann
Thaddäus Parade ist in lützerath
unaufhaltsam bewegt sich der
Schaufelradbagger Richtung lützerath
hier an der Abrisskante Herr Stuhr eine
trügerische Ruhe denn nur wenig weiter
rund um die besetzten Höfe ist die
Situation angespannt schwere
Räumfahrzeuge haben heute mit den ersten
Rodungen begonnen begleitet von einem
großen Polizeiaufgebot die Arbeiten
kommen nur langsam voran die Bergung von
klimaaktivisten hoch oben auf den
triports ist mühsam immer wieder kommt
es deshalb zu Tumult und lautstarken
Protesten Mara und ihre Mitstreiter
beobachten die Szenen die junge
klimaaktivistin liebt seit Monaten im
Protestcamp in retten und blickt mit
Sorge auf die kommenden Tage
was wir jetzt sehen ist dass die Polizei
schon die letzte Woche über ganz viele
Vorbereitungen gemacht hat und ganz viel
aufgebaut hat um wirklich diese Räumung
anzufangen und auch hier gibt es seit
dem frühen Morgenstunden so hin und her
geschiebe und mit stabilen
Menschenketten konnten wir aber bis
jetzt verhindern dass die Polizei
wirklich weiter vorrücken konnte es sind
nur wenige tausend Quadratmeter und ein
paar Höfe doch lützerat ist zum Symbol
geworden einer verfehlten Klimapolitik
viele hier fühlen sich verraten
besonders von denen die einst Seite an
Seite standen
der grüne Europaparlamentarier Michael
bloß ist zu Besuch und bekommt die ganze
Wut zu spüren
gemeinsam
schickt es brodelt gehörig nicht nur in
lützerath sondern auch an der grünen
Basis in Düsseldorf kippten
Umweltaktivisten eine Ladung
Kohlebriketts wo die Zentrale der Grünen
Landespartei der Dialog mit dem grünen
Landesvorsitzenden unerwünscht das
Vertrauen verspielt keine
Diskussionsveranstaltung diskutieren
hätten wir können vorher zu wenig leiden
und ich bin normalerweise immer du musst
mich auch ausreden lassen für einen
austauschen das haben wir auch immer
gemacht jetzt
die Grünen in Erklärungsnot denn als
Regierungspartei in NRW tragen sie
politische Mitverantwortung und werden
die Räumung von lützerath nicht mehr
stoppen wann und wie die Polizei hier
morgen vorrücken wird ist ungewiss eines
aber steht fest die Menschen in
lützerath wollen solange wie möglich
Widerstand leisten damit die Kohlebagger
nicht noch weiter vorrücken und das Dorf
gerettet wird
ganze 7 Häuser stehen noch in Lutzerath
die ursprünglichen Bewohner haben den
Ort längst verlassen sind von RWE
ausbezahlt worden lützerath ist zu einem
Symbol geworden für die einen ist es
Verrat an den Klimaschutzzielen für die
anderen Folge einer Realpolitik die sich
an Verträge halten muss wer hat Recht
wir ahnen schon auch auf diese Frage
wird es keine schwarz-weißantwort geben
aber Christian Kirsch hat die Fakten
jetzt
dutzende Dörfer sind in den vergangenen
100 Jahren in Deutschland den
Braunkohletagebau zum Opfer gefallen
jetzt also kurz vor dem Kohleausstieg
noch das kleine Blitzer Rad muss das
noch sein es ist auch unter Fachleuten
umstritten
der Deal in Nordrhein-Westfalen der
Ausstieg aus dem Braunkohletagebau wird
von 2038 auf 2030 vorgezogen dadurch
werden 280 Millionen Tonnen braun Kohle
nicht mehr abgebaut dafür darf im
Gegenzug noch lützerat weggebaggert
werden
Kohle gilt das besonders klimaschädlich
dennoch die Braunkohle liefert rund 20%
der deutschen Stromversorgung hinzu
kommt die Steinkohle die importiert wird
beide zusammen tragen zu etwa 30% der
Stromerzeugung in Deutschland bei das
kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
ersetzen aber zumindest auf einen Teil
der Kohlekraftwerke könnte man
verzichten denn Deutschland produziert
mehr Strom als nötig und exportiert
große Mengen an Strom
Braunkohlekraftwerke bleiben darüber
hinaus wegen der aktuellen Energiekrise
länger am Netz und brauchen Brennstoff
außerdem Kohle ist trotz massiv
gestiegener Preise relativ günstig
Stromproduktion im Gaskraftwerken ist
aufgrund der zwischenzeitlich extrem
hohen Gaspreise auf dem Weltmarkt teurer
als die Stromproduktion im
Kohlekraftwerken das wird sich ändern
Ende des Jahrzehnts so Fachleute wird
die Kohle Verstromung unwirtschaftlich
dann ist der CO2 Preis zu hoch
für lützerath aber kommt diese
Entwicklung zu spät das Dorf wird
verschwinden
dann gucken wir jetzt von einer
Ansammlung von Häusern deren größter
Schatz im Boden unter den Kellern liegt
aus einem von den Bewohnern verlassenen
mini-dorf eine Stunde entfernt von Köln
auf das große Bild nämlich auf unseren
Planeten dessen Zustand und Zukunft uns
alle angehen muss Niklas Höhne ist
Mitgründer des new climate Instituts und
Autor mehrerer Berichte des
Weltklimarats Herr Professor guten Abend
hallo Herr sius die einen kämpfen für
ihren Profit die anderen gegen den
Weltuntergang ist es so einfach
wir rasen derzeit in eine
Klimakatastrophe und das wirklich
teuerste Szenario ist das in dem wir
keinen Klimaschutz machen in dem
Szenario können wir auch gar keine
Profite mehr machen deswegen ist es
einfach sehr sehr wichtig dass wir jetzt
Klimaschutz betreiben und zu sagen ja
wir müssen das machen weil wir Profite
brauchen das ist eigentlich ein falsches
Argument wir haben die teuersten wird es
wenn wir gar keinen Klimaschutz machen
wenn Sie also jetzt Lutzerath hören
welche größere Herausforderung
symbolisierte in dieser kleine Ort in
ihren Augen
ja es geht im Prinzip nicht wirklich um
um den Ort lützerat sondern es geht
darum ob wir bereit sind als
Gesellschaft ambitionierte Klimapolitik
zu machen und die Situation ist die dass
wir ja quasi in eine Katastrophe Rasen
wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher und
der UN-Generalsekretär hat das genannt
ja Highway to Hell oder eben Autobahn in
die Hölle und das bedeutet wir müssen
jetzt so schnell wie möglich
Treibhausgasemissionen reduzieren und da
geht's nicht nur um nutzerat da geht es
darum eben andere Dinge zu tun ich äh
und ebenso schnell wie möglich zum
Beispiel wir bräuchten unbedingt schnell
einen Tempolimit wir müssen unbedingt
schnell Umsteuern mehr erneuerbare
Energien weniger Gas wir müssen
unbedingt weniger ja umweltschädliche
Subventionen ausgeben sondern die
kompensieren die viel ja klimawand
leiden und da müssen wir eigentlich
komplett Umsteuern wir müssen in einen
Notfallmodus geraten und nicht klein
klein halbherzige Kompromisse machen
jetzt sind wir auf der anderen Seite
natürlich in so ein bisschen anderen
Notfallmodus gerade und das ist ja das
Argument auch der Politik Stichwort
Ukraine Krieg Stichwort
Energiesicherheit Stichwort weg von
russischem Gas wie viel Kompromisse die
die Regierung da aktuell schließen muss
sind denn aus ihrer Sicht überhaupt noch
tragbar
ja wir sind in einer besonderen
Situation und ja eben gerade vor dem
Hintergrund einer ja vielleicht dass wir
zu wenig Gas haben und das Leute frieren
müssen und das vielleicht Industrien
abgeschaltet werden müssen das ist
natürlich ein ein schlimmes Szenario und
deshalb werden vielleicht Kompromisse
gemacht wir sind heute aber nach ein
paar Monaten dieser Krise schon schlauer
und wissen dass es vielleicht gar nicht
so schlimm kommt und aus
klimapolitischer Sicht können wir uns
wirklich gar keine Kompromisse mehr
leisten also wir müssen konsequent
handeln und nicht mehr halbherzig
Kompromisse machen und deswegen jede
Entscheidung wieder überdenken und auch
diese Entscheidung könnte man ja wenn
man will noch mal überdenken ist es denn
nun wirklich nötig und finden wir nicht
doch noch einen anderen Weg der alle
Seiten dann zufriedenstellend das wäre
aus meiner Sicht wirklich einen ein
wichtiger Schritt auch langfristig denn
wir müssen eine riesige Transformation
bekommen und diese Transformation
bekommen wir nur hin wenn wir das
gemeinsam machen und wenn man sich jetzt
bekämpft wie das gerade in Lutzerath der
Fall ist dann schaffen wir das ganz
sicherlich nicht das interessant was sie
sagen sie würden also auch sagen dann
muss man halt einen Vertrag der bereits
geschlossen ist mit RWE notfalls noch
mal aufkündigen komplett
na ich würde sagen dass man jetzt neue
Informationen hat wir sind ein paar
Monate weiter wir wissen was wir
wirklich brauchen für die
Versorgungssicherheit wir haben mehr
Studien zu der Lage und in so einem Fall
kann man sicherlich ja sagen wir können
vielleicht noch mal gucken ob wir da
noch eine andere Lösung finden eben
genau deswegen weil das ein
präsidenzfall ist wir müssen noch viele
andere sehr schwierige Entscheidungen
fällen und wenn wir die jetzt hier nicht
richtig hinbekommen weil es zum Konflikt
bekommt dann wird es sehr schwierig alle
anderen genauso schwierige Entscheidung
tatsächlich noch durchzubekommen
deswegen würde ich mir das schon sehr
wünschen ja gesagt Professor Niklas
Höhne vom new climate Institute Herr
Professor vielen Dank für das Gespräch
ich danke
das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am Abend aufgezeichnet so Hannah
jetzt du mit einer ersten
Nachrichtenübersicht und da schauen wir
zuerst Richtung USA in einem ehemaligen
Büro von US-Präsident beiden sind als
vertraulich oder geheim eingestufte
Regierungsdokumente aus seiner Zeit als
Vizepräsident gefunden worden das
US-Justizministerium prüft nun den
Vorfall laut dem Weißen Haus wurden die
Dokumente von beiden Anwälten in einem
verschlossenen Schrank entdeckt als
diese die privaten Büroräume ausräumten
der Fall erinnert an den Fund von
vertraulichen regierungspapieren im
Anwesen von exos-präsident Trump im
August hatten FBI Ermittler dort mehr
als 200 geheime Dokumente beschlagnahmt
auch wenn die Kinder Sterblichkeit seit
Jahren zurückgeht beklagt die UN dass
viele junge Menschen sterben obwohl ihre
Erkrankungen behandelbar wären nach
einer neuen Schätzung der UN stirbt
weltweit etwa alle 4,4 Sekunden ein
Mensch bis 24 Jahren südlich der Sahara
ist das Risiko eines frühen Todes 15 Mal
höher als in Europa oder Nordamerika ein
Großteil der Todesfälle könnte durch
bessere Gesundheits-
im Prozess um den spektakulären Juwelen
Diebstahl aus dem Grünen Gewölbe in
Dresden haben mehrere Angeklagte einem
Deal mit Gericht und Staatsanwaltschaft
zugestimmt sie sollen mildere Strafen
bekommen weil sie einen Großteil der
Beute zurückgegeben haben weitere
Voraussetzungen sein außerdem
umfangreiche und glaubhafte Geständnisse
erklärte der Vorsitzende Richter der
2019 gestohlene Schmuck der
zurückgegeben wurde ist laut
Zeugenaussage einer Expertin zum Teil
stark beschädigt
in Peru sind bei erneuten Protesten
gegen die Regierung mindestens 17
Menschen getötet worden das halte die
Ombudsstelle des Landes mit bei den
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Polizei
und Demonstranten sollen außerdem mehr
als 60 Personen verletzt worden sein
seit Wochen kommt es in Peru immer
wieder zu landesweiten Protesten die
sich gegen die Regierung von
übergangspräsidentin die Demonstranten
fordern Neuwahlen und die Freilassung
des inhaftierten Ex-Präsidenten Castillo
viele sorgenvolle Gesichter in den
Kommandozentralen der ukrainischen Armee
im Moment eine offensive Russlands kommt
offenbar mit neuer Taktik voran schauen
wir uns das mal an ganz im Osten rund um
die Stadtbach Mut dort sind die Kämpfe
gerade besonders heftig in der Stadt
Solidar direkt daneben ist die Lage hoch
angespannt sagt der ukrainische
Präsident es sind dort kaum noch intakte
Wände übrig sagt er die Millionenstadt
hakif war eines der ersten Angriffsziele
Russlands sie ist mittlerweile wieder in
ukrainischer Hand aber sie ist schwer
zerstört
-7 Grad nur 40 km entfernt von der
russischen Grenze noch nie seit Beginn
des Krieges war ein ausländischer
Außenminister dort vor Ort Anna Lena
bärburg ist heute die erste Tim Krüger
es ist nur eine Stück Visite und wohl
doch ein deutliches Signal in Richtung
Moskau als die deutsche Außenministerin
heute Mittag in hakiv aus dem Zug steigt
ist sie nur noch wenige Kilometer von
der russischen Grenze entfernt nur rund
vier Stunden wird sie bleiben Zeit genug
dennoch um die Wunden zu sehen die der
Krieg hier hinterlassen hat etwa das
Umspannwerk das erst vor wenigen Wochen
von russischen Raketen getroffen wurde
das heißt bei wie viel Haushalten fällt
jetzt der Strom aus oder wie viel
Prozent der Stromversorgung sind dadurch
betroffen man arbeite am Rande der
Möglichkeiten erklärt ihr der Gouverneur
und schalte auf andere Umspannwerke um
noch die Häuserfronten in Haki gespickt
mit Spanplatten Luftalarm ist an der
Tagesordnung die Menschen sind nach wie
vor auf alles gefasst in Schulen
entstehen Schutzräume neue Kabelstränge
Belüftungsanlagen Toiletten es ist die
Hoffnung dass die Schüler irgendwann
zurückkehren und nicht mehr nur online
lernen
weil es für die Kinder eine gewisse
Sozialisation ist sie sind jetzt alle zu
Hause sie sind getrennt voneinander und
lernen online sie brauchen aber den
Kontakt zueinander
bis die Kinder zurückkehren wird in
dieser Schule gekocht für die Menschen
in der Umgebung Heizung und Wasser sind
zwar meistens da viele aber haben keine
Arbeit kein Geld
den ganzen Krieg lang haben wir schon
kein Einkommen wir leben nicht wie
existieren
und doch halten sie durch Rake war eines
der ersten Ziele gleich nach
Kriegsbeginn viele sind geflohen aber
mehr als eine Million Menschen leben
derzeit in der Stadt und trotzen der
russischen Bedrohung
für eine Stadt belagert zerschossen
befreit spiegelt die ganze Furchtbarkeit
dieses brutalen russischen
Angriffskrieges wieder aber eben auch
den ganzen Mut die Widerstandsfähigkeit
und damit die Hoffnung für die Ukraine
auf ein Leben in Frieden noch aber toben
erbitterte Kämpfe vor allem in bachmut
in Solidar das ist nur etwas mehr als
200 km entfernt von bärbox besuchsort
und so begleitet die Außenministerin
auch die Debatte um die Lieferung von
deutschen Kampfpanzern
wir brauchen diese Panzer um unsere
Städte und unsere Dörfer befreien zu
können die sich unter russischer
Besatzung befinden
und die Entscheidung müsse schnell
fallen denn jeden Tag den der Krieg
länger dauert sterben in der Ukraine
mehr Menschen
Kampfpanzer will die Ukraine also in
dieser Situation auch und gerade von
Deutschland Florian Neuheim guten Abend
nach Brüssel ist denn da heute der Druck
aus Brüssel auf dem Bundeskanzler und
seine zurückhaltende Position in der
Frage gestiegen
ja diese ganze panzerdebatte ist ja fast
so alt wie dieser Krieg selbst und war
zuletzt wirklich ermüdend weil sich die
Debatte doch immer wieder im Kreis zu
drehen schienen aber in der Tat der
Druck ist noch mal deutlich gestiegen
auf Berlin und er kommt aus
verschiedenen Seiten einerseits aus
Polen dann aus Frankreich heute von der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin und dann gibt
es nicht dementierte medienberichte
wonach Großbritannien die Lieferung
erstmals von eigenen Kampfpanzern an die
Ukraine vorbereitet schon nächste Woche
könnt ihr die Regierung das in Rammstein
bei einem Treffen dort verkünden und
dann in viele das wohl wichtigste
Gegenargument das Olaf Scholz bisher
vorgebracht hat nämlich dass er keinen
in Deutschland allein gegangen möchte
insofern da gibt es offenbar noch mal
etwas Bewegung es gibt aber auch Florian
ein wichtiges Thema da muss ich die EU
an die eigene Nase fassen sie besiegelt
heute eine neue militärische
Zusammenarbeit mit der NATO soll das
jetzt die neue europäische Strategie
sein also der Ruf nach NATO und damit
auch nach Amerika
naja über wenig reden europäische
Spitzenpolitiker so gern wie über
europäische Souveränität gerade in
Fragen der Sicherheit und dann liest man
dann heute diese neue Vereinbarung
zwischen der EU und NATO und stößt auf
die harte Realität denn da heißt es
Zitat die NATO bleibt die Grundlage
unserer Verteidigung und essentiell für
unsere eurotransonantische Sicherheit
heißt übersetzt wenn es hart auf hart
kommt dann ist Europa doch noch
angewiesen weiterhin auf die Stärke der
NATO und damit auf die USA und das gilt
auch erst recht für unsere erstes Thema
nämlich die Waffenlieferungen denn da
liefern die USA ja weiterhin deutlich
mehr als jedes europäische Land die
große Frage da ist nur was passiert wenn
sich der politische Wind in den USA
wieder drehen sollte interessante
Analyse wie immer Florian Brüssel
herzlichen Dank
Umwelt und Verkehr ist jetzt dein Thema
Hannah ja geht es darum die Klimaziele
zu erreichen ist in Deutschland der
Verkehrssektor ein besonders großes
Sorgenkind wichtiges Treffen also heute
im Bundeskanzleramt dort trafen sich
Vertreter aus Politik Wissenschaft und
Wirtschaft zum mobilitätsgipfel weil
realer in Frankfurt was ist denn
schlussendlich bei dem Treffen
herumgekommen es waren ja in zwei
Stunden angesetzt da war schon irgendwie
im Vorfeld klar dass man die vielen
Themen allenfalls Streifen konnte großes
Thema war natürlich die E-Mobilität
Regierung und Autobranche haben noch
einmal ihr Ziel bekräftigt bis 2030
mindestens 15 Millionen E-Autos auf die
Straßen zu bringen mit dem jetzigen
Tempo ist das allerdings kaum zu
schaffen ja und in dem Zusammenhang
wurde aber auch über die Lade
Infrastruktur gesprochen da war man sich
einig dass sie ausgebaut werden muss da
will man deutlich mehr Tempo machen
wobei die Regierung da vor allem die
Wirtschaft am Zug sieht
und dann gab es ja auch schon im Vorfeld
viele Kritikpunkte an dem Treffen stimmt
die gab es zum Beispiel an der
Zusammensetzung der Gäste zu einseitig
wurde bemängelt große Autokonzerne waren
ja geladen Batteriehersteller und
Halbleiter Produzenten nicht aber
Interessenvertreter von Fahrrad Bahn und
öffentlichem Nahverkehr die fühlten sich
dann auch übergangen aus
Regierungskreisen aber hieß es das sei
nur ein erstes Treffen gewesen bei den
folgenden würden dann die Themen
wechseln ja aber wie die ganz große
Verkehrswende gelingen soll das konnte
der Gipfel heute nicht beantworten
darüber ist sich aber selbst die Ampel
nicht einig die Liberalen wollen weiter
Autobahnen bauen die Grünen sind dagegen
und so wird es wohl noch einige Gipfel
geben müssen um eine gemeinsame Linie zu
finden auch innerhalb der Regierung
vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
München ist nach Angaben des
amerikanischen
verkehrsdienstleisters in Rix erneut die
staugeplagt dass der Stadt Deutschlands
wie schon im Vorjahr standen auch 2022
die Pendler hier am längsten im Stau
nämlich durchschnittlich 74 Stunden
Platz zwei und drei belegten Berlin um
Hamburg
Spitzenreiter weltweit ist London mit
insgesamt
156 Stunden
wir Lebensmittel aus Abfallcontainern
von Supermärkten holten macht sich
bislang strafbar Justizminister
Buschmann und Landwirtschaftsminister
mir setzten sich nun dafür ein dass zu
ändern in einem gemeinsamen Brief an die
Justizministerinnen und Minister der
Länder werden sie für einen Vorschlag
des Bundeslands Hamburg demnach soll das
Containern legalisiert werden sofern
weder Sachbeschädigung noch
Hausfriedensbruch vorliegen dies könnte
von den Bundesländern auch ohne eine
Gesetzesänderung auf Bundesebene
beschlossen werden
das Unwort des Jahres 2022 lautet
klima-terroristen eine Jury der
Universität Marburg die einen sachlichen
Sprachgebrauch anmahnt kritisierte das
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten dadurch mit
Terroristen gleichgesetzt und so
kriminalisiert und diffamiert würden auf
Platz 2 landet der Begriff
sozialtourismus er mache Stimmung gegen
Kriegsflüchtlinge und suggeriere ein
freiwilliges Reisevergnügen
was haben ein Industrie vor Ort von
Athen eine kleine ungarische Uni-Stadt
und der Ort an dem Rumäniens Revolution
1989 begann gemeinsam
zwölf Monate Aufmerksamkeit denn alle
drei sind Kulturhauptstädte Europas 2023
eher ein bisschen abseits der Turi
Routen wollen alle drei zeigen was in
ihnen steckt Timmi schwara in Rumänien
ist dabei geradezu ein Musterbeispiel
für Europas Vielfalt an einem Ort
wolf-christian Ulrich nimmt uns mit
Familienprojekt dran das nennt sich der
Kirchgarten das im Theater nicht nur auf
Rumänisch sondern auch auf ungarische
und Deutsch gespielt wird ist in
Timisoara eine Selbstverständlichkeit
Schauspielerin Johanna jakob hat erst in
der Schule Deutsch gelernt und spielt
jetzt auf Deutsch Theater
ich liebe meine Heimat ab und zu habe
ich auch mal auf Rumänisch gespielt und
komischerweise das erste Mal wo ich auf
Rumänisch gespielt habe kam mir das
komisch vor obwohl das meine
Muttersprache war weil ich so ein eine
sprachstrategie auf Deutsch entwickelt
habe und ich mich in dieser Sprache
irgendwie auch wohlfühle die viel
völkerstat Timisoara empfängt Europa mit
offenen Armen
Timisoara vibriert und ist
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich selbst in
diesem Krisenzeiten hält das
multikulturelle Netz der Stadt erzählt
Watt tauschanische vom
Organisationskomitee
hier leben etwa 20 unterschiedliche
Kulturen zusammen in schwierigen Zeiten
wie diesen sind ja manche versucht im
fremden den Sündenbock zu sehen aber die
Leute hier behalten einen kühlen Kopf
und darauf bin ich wirklich stolz
die Stadt die Freiheit atmet in
Timisoara begann 1989 die rumänische
Revolution tausende demonstrierten
damals gegen das brutale schau
schesco-regime das dann auf seine Bürger
schießen ließ viele Demonstranten
starten dabei aber dann kam die Freiheit
die Politik und die Kunst kommen dem
Kulturjahr zusammen wir besuchen Anna
Kuhn die Künstlerin bringt das auf den
Teller was Leuten politisch auf der
Seele brennt die sonst nie im
Vordergrund stehen die helfenden Hände
im Kulturjahr Köche Putzhilfen
museumswerte das schmeckt mir nicht
heißt ihr Projekt Tiere zu töten
schmeckt mir nicht
Abtreibungsgegner schmecken mir nicht
die hohen Preise schmecken mir auch
nicht
[Musik]
politisch was wir machen hat eine
politische Bedeutung die über die
Kunstwelt hinausgeht
Anna möchte mit ihrer Kunst erreichen
dass Migration Gentrifizierung und
Arbeitsbedingungen ein Gesprächsthema
werden in diesem Kulturjahr
mag sind die vielen unabhängigen
Ateliers und ich glaube auch dass ein
großer Teil der off-kultur von Timisoara
im Kulturhauptstadt ja repräsentiert
sein wird
es wird ein spannendes Kulturjahr ist
ein ganz besonderer europäischer
Kulturort
und wie sagt der Bürgermeister der
rumänischen Stadt der übrigens aus dem
Schwarzwald stammt und früher mal
Redenschreiber von Altbundespräsident
Horst Köhler war Timmi schwara ist
deutlich europäischer als das Dorf in
dem ich aufgewachsen bin weil es sehr
viel besser mit Mehrsprachigkeit und dem
Nebeneinander von Ideen umgehen kann
eine Stadt die definitiv eine Reise
lohnt ja und jetzt noch der Hinweis auf
unser heute journal Update gegen 0:30
Uhr mit Nazan Gag der mir von uns allen
hier Danke fürs Interesse angenehm Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend in fast ganz Deutschland
sind das jetzt die mindesten ersten zehn
januar-tage die es je gab seit Beginn
regelmäßiger Wetteraufzeichnungen und es
bleibt mild heute Nacht fällt Regen von
der Küste bis zu den Alpen selten ist
man etwas Schnee dabei bevor der Regen
ankommt kann es auch mal aufklären da
wird es glatt zumindest in Bayern denn
dort sinken die Temperaturen auf 0 bis
-4 Grad sonst bleibt die Nacht milder
die Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 6 Grad in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und 12 Grad am Rhein der
Regen der Nacht sieht morgen über Tag
weiter auswärts dahinter lockern die
Wolken wieder auf wie hier im Nordwesten
bei südwestend und es wird kräftig
weiter regnen bis Samstagabend können
bis zu 100 Liter Regensburg Quadratmeter
z.B im Sauerland oder im Schwarzwald
zusammenkommen es geht also verregnet
windig und mit wenig Sonne weiter Schnee
im Flachland weiterhin fehlanzeige
alle Bäume und grünes Land erinnern uns
an ein schützenswertes Biotop das Moor
wichtiger Kohlenstoffspeicher zentral im
Klimaschutz heute kam der aktuelle
mooratlas heraus bei uns gibt es die
meisten Moore im Norden und im
Alpenvorland das waren aber schon mal
mehr über 90% der Moore sind entwässert
bebaut oder landwirtschaftlich genutzt
zerstörte Moore setzen in kurzer Zeit
große Mengen CO2 frei sie wieder zu
vermessen ist das Ziel engagierten
Klimaschutzes Entwässerungsgräben werden
dafür mühsam verfüllt das lohnt sich
denn mit der Zeit steigt der Wasserstand
und es bildet sich neuer Taufe
mehr Kohlenstoff als alle anderen
Ökosysteme guten Abend